remember when the internet was supposed
to spread freedom and democracy around
the world it's helped people organize
protest and fight for democratic reforms
but increasingly authoritarian regimes
are using the Internet to undermine
democracy by the monitoring citizen's
silencing critics or just simply cutting
the cord altogether in fact according to
one study the number of Internet
shutdowns
has doubled since 2016 and more than 70%
of Internet users now live in countries
where people were arrested for posting
political social or religious content
and when it comes to controlling the
internet experts saying there's one
country that's leading the way and
teaching others how to do it China it's
it's basically pioneered and just
dominated this form of kind of Internet
control and you look at it and you go ok
we can do that
let's try that it's not too difficult to
seek to track the trend in Beijing's
influence and Beijing's training and all
these forms of Internet control that
China pioneered appearing in Africa for
two decades China has been building its
own version of the internet sealed off
by the Great Firewall which blocks
sensors and controls anything that the
ruling party doesn't like and now
China's trying to export its model the
internet around the world
Beijing calls this cyber sovereignty
something President Xi Jinping promotes
to other leaders at China's annual world
internet conference ginger Wong look
they kind of crafted this doctrine of
cyber sovereignty it says look just as
we control what goes on inside the
physical borders of our country we
should be able to control absolutely
what goes on in the you know cyber
borders of our country it's basically
using sovereignty arguments and national
security arguments as a justification
for censorship China isn't just
spreading its ideology it's also sharing
its technology companies with links to
the ruling party like Huawei are
building Internet infrastructure in
countries all over the world
particularly in Africa experts believe
that this could give those nations the
same surveillance powers that China has
there are lots of places that you can
see this investment and then see this
yeah this spike in censorship China has
also trained leaders from nearly 40
different nations on its surveillance
tactics including Uganda after its 2016
elections in the wake of that election
when the government was complaining
about people how people are organized in
social media and explaining why it had
to you know shut down social media
people sounds good and some Ugandan
officials did go to Beijing and openly
said we are going to Beijing to learn
how to deal with this problem with the
internet come in the wake of cracking
down on dissent in Uganda you know I
think it was pretty clear what they were
hoping to learn from from Beijing there
are two competing models of the internet
one is China's the other is more open
and decentralized but right now it looks
like China's is making serious progress
that's partly because the open model has
so many problems of its own from fake
news and political hackings to
real-world violence
China is able to say these aren't really
problems in China because we tightly
control our internet and we tightly
police them if countries that care about
the internet of companies that care
about Internet and organizations don't
come up with a effective new model then
you know I think we will see a trend
towards a more top-down government
control as in China as in Russia as in
much of Africa you know we'll see that
even in countries that have typically
you know stuck up for a free inner
you